All right, we've come nearly to the end of our course. What I'd
like to do now is summarize what I think are the high points, that
is the most important testing principles that
I've tried to convey in this course,
and put them all in one place. So, let's go through these. First of
all, testers must want software to fail.
Second, testers are like detectives who are
hunting down bugs. And as detectives, testers will have to be observant to all
sorts of suspicious behaviors and anomalies in
the software of your test. My guess
is that a number of really serious bugs that have occurred over the years.
I think these had already been noticed by people and swept under the rug because
people were busy or they just wanted to ship the product or maybe they were
users who didn't know what the bugs meant. So regular users have the luxury of
ignoring bugs, but testers don't, and so
it's really important not to sweep things under
the rug. All available test oracles should be used as a basis for testing. And
so, you might be tempted to think from the language that I was using, that
is, strong oracles versus weak ones, that if we had a couple of good strong
oracles available, maybe we wouldn't need the
weak ones, maybe we wouldn't just use them
at all. And as I hope I've convinced you by now, that's not
the case at all. All of the oracles should be used because they
can all detect different kinds of faults, and even if they detect the
same faults, weak oracles might be much cheaper to use. Test cases should
contain values selected from the entire input domain, and if there's doubt about
what exactly that domain is, this is something that will be good to
hash out with the developers. Interfaces that cross a trust boundary need to
be tested with all representable values, not
just those from the ostensible input domain.
If we recall some of the examples we've looked at, if we are writing
a web server we might hope everybody
submits data that's well-formatted, but as its
most likely the case, they won't and the reason they won't is because they
will be trying to break into our Web site. Server. So we need to test
on that kind of data, to ensure that we can correctly reject it. Similarly,
a piece of software like the Linux kernel has the trust boundary at the
system call interface, that is to say
the interface between user mode applications and
the Linux kernel. Linux kernel like the
web server, can't trust that its clients are
going to make well formed requests all the time. It should expect
that its clients if not actually hostile, are at least buggy,
and are going to do all kinds of, it needs to
catch that instead of crashing or violating its security policy. A little
brute force goes a long ways when we're testing. And what
I mean in particular is in certain restricted circumstances, we can
do exhaustive testing and almost anything else can be randomly tested.
Quality cannot be tested into bad software. We saw the Therac 25
example, where the control software for
the radiation therapy machine was probably
so broken, that almost an, almost no amount of testing would have been
sufficient to make it right. It needed to be thrown away I
think I needed to start over. I'm sure we've all seen software that
looked like that. So in contrast with examples like a fair at
25, testable software has a few of the following qualities. No hidden coupling
between modules and side channels where
modules can share information without being
visible to the system developers. A
few variables but are shared between threads.
Few global variables shared between modules. And no pointer soup,
and that is to say, no huge data structures with pointers
going everywhere where it can't possibly keep track of who's
changing what and what's valid and what's not. Codes should be
self checking whenever possible using plenty of assertions. However, these
assertions are never used for error checking, rather they're used to
check for logically impossible conditions. It implies some sort of an
internal consistency violation. Assertions must
never be side effecting, because if
they are, and you turn them off, the system behavior will change,
and this leads to madness among
developers. Finally, these assertions should never
be silly or trivial ones, because first of all, those serve no
purpose, second, they clutter up code,
third, they make things slower, and finally,
they fail to communicate useful information to the next person who looks
at the code When appropriate, all 3 sources of input to a piece
of software under test should be used a a basis for testing.
And those include the obvious API's, provided by the software on your test
which can be tested directly. API's used by the software
under test can be tested using fault injections techniques. So
recall that these are things like substituting the library that
provides these API's with a different library the inject faults, well
perhaps just hacking the layer underneath to inject faults. Finally,
non-functional inputs such as thread schedules need to be tested using
whatever method you can get that will work to actually
test these things. And finally, the last principle for testing is
that failed code coverage do not provide a mandate to cover the failed
items, no matter how tempting that might be, but rather, they give clues to
ways in which the test we did is inadequate. So, blindly coding to
the coverage metric is going to destroy those clues, but it's going to do it in
such a way that doesn't improve the quality of the test suite very
much. So taken together, this list of
items I've just given you constitutes pretty
much all that I know about testing. And the detailed version of these
has been the content of this course. This is material that I have never
taught before, so I hope it came out in sort of a fairly coherent
fashion. It's stuff that's been brewing in my mind for a long time. I've
wanted to teach it because I've noticed for years that we don't seem to
be doing a very good job teaching CS students to test. What happens instead is
they write small test cases in response
to assignments, they debug them until they
pass the test cases we give them, hand them in and never look at them
again. And it's hard to think of anything less like the real world of
software development than the environment we create
in classes. So what I have tried to
do is structure this course a bit little differently,
tried to bring out thing that I feel are
really important that we often don't do a very
good job with. And this has been really enjoyable for
me, it's been great to actually try and set
this material down in a coherent fashion and I very
much hope that this material has been useful for
you and that the class has been enjoyable. Thank you.